alter spéc sion c'est le nom que la
plasticienne viviane zannier a donné à
son installation jusqu'au 20 février
prochain elle investira la commanderie
de saint quentin en yvelines à travers
ces textiles entremêlés l'artiste
souhaite transmettre des émotions tout
l'espace est fait pour que le public
puisse venir et
ressentir quelque chose est en fait ce
qui m'intéresse c'est que le public et
ce moment là c'est à dire que l'oeuvre
soit plus un vecteur d'émotions est un
vecteur de senti plutôt que tout
simplement la traduction d'une émotion
quelconque initialement son oeuvre
invitait les visiteurs à toucher ses
formes mais il a fallu s'adapter mon
travail de manière générale et tactile
intégralement donc évidemment avec
l'occident n'a pas pu être possible tout
ce travail a été repensé pour qu'il soit
cowitz anglais la plasticienne a
également été en résidence à la
commanderie l'organisation est fier
désormais de lui consacrer un espace
j'ai vu vraiment beaucoup travaillé et
je suis très heureux d'enfin pouvoir
montrer son travail qui a été vraiment
pour le coup la pensée pour le grand
atelier dans la commanderie et je trouve
que c'est elle en a fait vraiment un
lieu magique j'espère que les gens vont
penser ça aussi
l'installation est liée à celle d'un
autre artiste nicolas henry le
photographe plasticien et metteur en
scène il présente cabane imaginaire et
esprits de la nature un vernissage de
deux expositions est prévue le 12
février prochain viviane sagnier
interprétera d'ailleurs une performance
dansée au milieu de son installation